why you should learn how to create and
use a cloud storage bucket cloud storage
is an online object storage web service
that's used to store and access data on
Google Cloud it can store large amounts
of data to help you do things like big
data analytics hostatic websites or
backup and archive data within cloud
storage there are resources called
storage buckets they hold your data and
help organize and control access to it
let's say this wrench hammer and
screwdriver are your data just like you
put these in a toolbox to store for easy
access when building something you can
put your data in a storage bucket for
easy access for your Cloud projects try
it out with this tutorial you'll learn
how to create a cloud storage bucket
upload objects to it move them around
remove public access to the bucket and
delete the objects inside of it cloud
storage even has a free tier that comes
with five gigabytes of storage per month
so you can try it out for free check out
the pinned comment for a link to the
tutorial now you know